in close constellations with partners
and allied around the world byteman and
administration will weigh 2022 beijing
games for us this is associated press
story the state department said tuesday
the biden administration is consulting
with allies about a joint approach to
china and its human rights record
including how to handle
the upcoming beijing winter olympics
human rights groups are protesting
china's
hosting of the games which are set to
start in february 2022
they have urged a diplomatic or
straight-up boycott of the event to call
attention to alleged chinese abuse
against
uh against uh tibetans and residents of
hong kong
the beijing winter olympics opened
february for 2022 to china
and china is denied all charge of human
rights abuses it says political motives
underlie the boycott efforts both the
internal olympics
committee and the u.s olympic and uh
paralympic
committee have said in the past a po
they oppose boycotts
thoughts yeah well i think number one
there's two
there's two sides to this um china is
committing human rights uh atrocities
against the uyghurs
and i guess tibetans as well but i think
that everything that's going on in the
uyghurs which is basically the west
the west side of china uh west side
where ricky's from
that is a true thing that's going on
there is human right abuses going on in
china
it is happening but if i'm biden or if
i'm the bite administration
i have to have a bigger perspective here
and win the war not the battle
battling over whether or not we should
compete in the olympics
is bs to me it's like that's not where
you should be fighting
uh your battle here we have a massive
situation going on with china with the
trade war and everything that's going on
and tariffs and everything
and everything that's associated with
china and competing for the top spot in
the economy
this is not the place that we want to
have
um the the war go down over the freaking
olympics so
pick and choose your battles if you're
biden and yes they are
committing human rights atrocities that
is true
no fan of china and what they're doing
but this is the stage
to basically voice your concerns that's
my opinion do you boycott or do you not
boycott i do not boycott
no no no not meaning america
should we keep olympics in china beijing
2022 yes
we should yes and people around the
world should comfortably go to china
even the coronavirus has been documented
i came out of wuhan
three years later if this is if this is
where
um if this is where the olympics is
scheduled
the is this the winter olympics yes the
winter olympics
so something that i've uh come to terms
with is
multilateralism over unilateralism if
multiple countries if nato comes out or
and if a whole
of a squad of countries and says look
we're the eu we're australia we're
canada we're united states
we're this this this and this and we're
all coming together and saying uh uh uh
uh uh
but to go at it alone unilateralism
which trump sort of coined
that is not the look that i want biden
doing so if a collective effort says
this is what we are
all doing i'm in favor of that going at
it alone against china
who who right now is against it kai who
right now is against it
who's right now against it about having
the winter olympics in china
ricky do you have any thoughts on this
um you know i'm kind of i'm kind of torn
pat when it comes down to this because
i i think that what ends up happening is
that you know i
i have a lot of friends that are chinese
right and you know
they're good people you know they're not
bad people these are people that are
very loving and
um smart smart individuals and uh as a
as a country you know i i don't know if
you do you do or what do i guess what
we're trying to do is
who are we punishing by boycotting it
the
the people or the country or the
government i mean we're dude by
boycotting this we're
we're saying that we don't agree with
something so what is it that we don't
agree with i mean how are we so
comfortable taking other material
why are we comfortable uh buying other
stuff for a cheap rate but now you don't
want to host the olympics
for the biggest distributor of goods in
the world i mean that's kind of
contradicting
right uh we haven't with the trade war
that we won
uh by the way one we didn't win i'm
sorry
we won the trade war we didn't win the
trade war trump didn't want the trouble
if there's anyone winning trump didn't
win the trade war no he didn't
okay that's not the conversation i don't
think there's been any winners in this
i'm gonna stick to pat's conversation so
the question becomes
we're okay doing business with them
we're okay taking their stuff we're okay
having our
things made over there but now you want
to boycott the olympics kind of crazy to
me i mean i don't like a communist
country anymore than anybody else does
but
uh i think it's contradicting as much
dealings as he has and his son has
with china which i recorded him being a
what is a ceo cfo or chairman of one of
the
uh chinese companies that paid them i
don't know how many millions of dollars
now you want to go act like you're mad
at them
i'm not with them bro you know pick a
side and stick to it
to me it's a couple different things to
me one it's i don't know
about you know maybe we flip
and give somebody spot for 2022 and let
the world calm down with china for a
decade before we bring olympics back to
them
i think it's a little too sensitive it's
a it's like
you know it's like a divorce that
happens and
christmas is around the corner and you
still expect the mom and dad and
everybody to come together and have
spend christmas together it's just it's
a little fresh it's a little fresh for
us to do it
let's give a little bit of time to get
everybody come together maybe a year
from now
we'll come back and do this we just had
the world shut down because of china
let's face it that's true we had the
world shut down because of
one country's lack of responsibility
that somehow some way
a virus comes out of there and the world
takes a hit because of it
economy jobs restaurants lives
people loved ones careers
well all this stuff that's happened the
last 12 months because of
one country and yet we want to keep it
there for 2022.
i'm not saying we permanently boycott it
i say you need a couple years give it a
couple of seasons
i want to postpone them i don't want to
postpone the olympics because it is
unfair for the athlete listen
you know i watch uh uh when i see like
when you were telling me the story the
other day
you told the story to me i took the
story in a different one because i
looked at you as my son not that you're
my son we're two years apart
when he told a story about you know you
uh when the way
adrian said it he was emotional because
of how much he loves you he said
look we're living in colorado adam wants
to make a career and being a comedian
he wants to go out there and be a
comedian and wants to make it into the
nba so he's going out to playing ball
all this other stuff he starts playing
basketball with these guys that are
denver nuggets guys then they say
there's an open tryout
it's a d league whatever the league was
for you to come through so the same day
you're going to go to the triad you tell
adrian look just come and pick me up at
nine o'clock
i got a flight at one o'clock my dad's
paying a flight i haven't seen this guy
for four years i'm gonna go to vegas and
spend time with him right the story
you're telling
so i'm just kind of really curious with
the story so haven't seen pops for a few
years you're gonna go see him in vegas
your dad's obviously not here with us
today but you're gonna go see him in
vegas
and uh but you're not like i'm not gonna
make it to the nba let's face it i'm
just going in there seeing what happens
so you go
and then you text adrian like dude you
won't believe it i made it past the
first round okay
and what are you talking about yeah i'm
going to the next one so pick me up at
10 o'clock
and then you go and you play you're
killing it and you make the second cut
dude what are you talking about dude i'm
still not gonna make it just pick me up
at 11 o'clock
you're going you make it past the third
oh just pick me up at the fourth
you know four you and you make it past
fourth you throw some labs
dunks all this stuff that's happening
visually he's selling it to me on what
happened to it
and then finally you're one cut away
shaun c phillips nephew apparently made
it i don't know
he made cousin makes it and uh it could
have been you you're one cut away from
playing for being on a roster of the uh
denver nuggets having your own base
basketball card adam sosner okay
and then all of a sudden you run out and
you say i can't do it you're running out
to go see your dad
you chose that over your sport you're
running after you see kiki
and evander way yeah he says kid what
are you doing you can actually have a
shot it says listen i'd love to do
anything with the denver organization
here's
give me your number you exchange numbers
you get on the flight you go to vegas
just to see your dad and your dad says
what are you doing you should have gone
to the tryouts right we wanted to go
spend time with your dad so
what's the moral of the story these kids
have been training for years to go to
the olympics we cannot punish them yes
it is not fair to punish the people that
have been training their at the parents
that took the kids to tryouts
to practice the endless hours of clothes
driving them traveling the investment
it's a lot of pain
so the athlete cannot take the hit so we
can't cancel it
we simply have to relocate it to a
different place but we have to tell
china listen
it's sensitive right now it is sensitive
right now
we're not canceling you we are
postponing you
let's let the dust settle we'll come
back 10 years from now
and consider giving you the next slot
when it opens up maybe in 2026
but just not in 2022 so let's pick a
place
that's done this before salt lake city
utah let's pick a place there's plenty
of places that have done the winter
olympics before
pick a country maybe it's the last on
the list bring them up right now that's
20 years from now give them that slot
and then let's give them some of the
commerce that people trust a little bit
more that they've handled
coveted maybe better than some other
countries happening let's go over there
okay let's go over there and by the way
then the challenge even becomes some
countries that don't even want the
olympics to come to them
japan may say we've done this all right
i don't even want you to come to us i
get of course and i don't blame them but
you have a pool of countries that would
say
we'll take it i guarantee you there's 10
countries that would love to take them i
guarantee you
salt lake city may sit there and say
look if you want to come out here we'll
figure it out if you want to go to
new york and you want to go to what
what's that city of uh in new york where
they
practice uh lake placid yeah lake placid
there is options i just think it's
sensitive there's one group that i've
been to lake placid the whole illusion
place i've been there before
the one community that cannot take a hit
is the kids
the athletes yeah the parents for it
it's so emotional man yeah
it is so emotional so because we don't
know if they'll make the cut the next
year exactly
it's four years four years a long time
it's a once in a lifetime type of thing
exactly exactly so anyways we'll see
what's going to happen with that but
that's my thoughts but by far spider
doesn't have a
history of caring about people in any
way so it doesn't really matter
don't offend at them like that i don't
just officially
just to chime in i wholeheartedly agree
with you yeah it's a great story i i
totally it's your story
thank you i appreciate that um one cut
away from the nugget summer league team
um but if he if we do do this it needs
to be a collective decision biden can't
be the one making this decision
and something tells me that i don't
think it's gonna i don't think it's
gonna happen china does need to pay a
price
but by the way there was just a report
that just came out
w.h.o i don't know how much you how much
stock you put into them
they came out and they said there's a
very very high likelihood
that the covid 19 virus came from
the wet market not a lab thoughts
do we really want to go there buddy i
just want to know your thoughts i mean
first of all
who who who funds uh the world health
organization we do
that's why well no china does not us
they're number one we're number two
right and
trump even pulled out right so yeah i
don't even want to do anything but you
know biking's kind of coming back
out quote-unquote independent report i
don't know
we'll find the i mean kai maybe you can
find the report i just want to know
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye